هربوا مما هو مر الى ما هو امر
مهاجرون من منطقه القرن الافريقي من
اثيوبيا والصومال قطعوا مضيق باب المندب
الى اليمن وكلهم امل في ان يجد الامان
لكنهم لم يواجهوا غير القسوه والغدر
في الحرب لقتل اليمن واذا رفضوا تلقوا اشد
العقوبه
قاتل اذا اشتري قاتل نحنا بلادنا من زمان
وطلبنا اليمنيين الامان وطلب الغماء
[موسيقى]
كبير بحق الافارقه والمهاجرين سواء كان
المهاجرين الشرعيه
قامت كان في هناك محرقه عملتها مليشيات
الحوثي هذه المحرقه عنها مقتل المئات
وحريق يعني عدد كبير من هؤلاء طارق
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده سجلت وصول اكثر من 73.000 مهاجرين
افريقي الى اليمن خلال العام الماضي ياتون
الى اليمني ليتمكنوا من تقديم طلبات
الهجره او اللجوء من خلال الس الاجنبيه
والمنظمات الانسانيه
لكنهم لا يجدون الاضطهاد والعنف والتجنيد
القسري من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي العربيه